ça c'est un blender à qui permet
de faire des jus des smoothies sans
électricité
ça c'est une marmite norvégienne ça
permet d'économiser de l'énergie lors de
la cuisson ça c'est un four solaire ça
permet de cuire des aliments avec
l'énergie du soleil hop et là on est
dans notre atelier en arrière on met au
point tout ce système alternatifs
de notre consommation et aller dans un
sens de réduire une consommation
énergétique en général et c'est
important de savoir que les systèmes le
texte n'auront pas l'efficience des
machines électriques il faut pas
s'attendre à remplacer l'énergie
électrique
gros points communs aussi de tous ces
objets c'est que on peut les fabriquer
soi-même comment on est arrivé à faire
tout ça on va vous raconter notre
histoire
[Musique]
tout a commencé avec sa camion
d'expérimentation pendant 4 ans ça a été
notre lieu de vie à plein temps donc là
on a ici un espace couchage on remet la
banquette comme ça et on dort dans ce
sens là il y a plein de choses qu'on a
rencontré sur la route qu'on a fabriqué
sur la route qu'on a laissé du coup dans
les lieux où on est passé et qu'on avait
envie de répliquer pour pouvoir les
utiliser vraiment en comprendre
l'efficience se faire nous même notre
opinion quoi on appelle ça la recherche
action c'est c'est découvrir quelque
chose le répliquer le tester
allez c'est parti
c'était un camion de pompiers volontaire
il y avait un objectif personnel de se
rendre compte de nos consommations
être capable de voir si les solutions
qu'on prône en terme de lothèque et ben
elles étaient viables ou intéressantes à
mettre au point dans un camion et il y
avait un but professionnel de pouvoir
trimballer notre atelier un peu partout
où on en avait envie de créer des objets
et puis sensibiliser au métier de la
fabrication quand on arrive sur un lieu
ça fait partie du spectacle
et ça nous permet de tracter une
remorque qu'on a transformé en atelier
donc il y a deux établis face à face
donc là de chaque côté il y a des racks
matériaux bois et de l'autre côté métal
et de ce côté
c'est la quincaillerie
l'enjeu étant d'aller dans des écoles
des MJC des foyers des maisons de
quartier auprès de com pour donner des
ateliers de fabrication donc on va faire
construire des forces solaires on va
faire construire des séchoirs des
éoliennes donc ça c'est un zerpote un
frigo du désert et ça permet de
reproduire l'environnement d'une cave et
ça c'est une petite éolienne 5 ou 12
volts c'est quelque chose qu'on tient à
garder disponible et être applicable par
le plus grand nombre donc l'important
c'est pas de vendre un objet fini ça va
être plus être de donner les clés pour
fabriquer soi-même l'objectif en fait de
d'avoir un catalogue si on peut dire
c'est d'expérimenter c'est de pas
forcément tendre vers l'autonomie ou la
réduction d'un seul pôle c'est d'être
capable d'envisager un peu la globalité
on a l'utilisation du soleil comment on
va utiliser le soleil au mieux pour
cuire sécher produire de l'eau chaude
voilà des choses comme ça l'énergie
mécanique ça va aussi bien de la machine
à laver au blender en passant par un
batteur de cuisine des machines
d'atelier enfin l'utilisation elle peut
être elle peut être multiple et c'est ça
qui nous intéresse c'est couvrir un peu
tous les champs tous les champs de
dépendance qu'on peut avoir